una tormenta de invierno se cobró la
vida de al menos 22 personas en eeuu y
méxico el sur de eeuu no estaba
preparado para algo así el estado de
texas registró temperaturas más frías
que en algunas partes de alaska las
gélidas temperaturas dificultaron el
tránsito terrestre y obligaron a
cancelar miles de vuelos la alta demanda
de energía colapsó la red y dejó a más
de 4 millones de personas sin
electricidad y a pesar de estar
reactivando el servicio más de un millón
siguen sin suministro eléctrico la
situación generó críticas al gobierno
estatales es bastante grave que como
texano no estemos preparados para el
frío en cualquier otra parte del país
esto ni siquiera habría sido un problema
si la tormenta de invierno también
provocó un fuerte tornado en carolina
del norte en el otro lado de la frontera
en mexico la situación también es
bastante crítica estados fronterizos
como chihuahua coahuila tamaulipas y
nuevo león se vieron impactados por los
cortes eléctricos y heladas temperaturas
de hasta menos 15 grados centígrados los
cortes de electricidad llegaron hasta la
zona que se enfrenta a 11
días sin suministro ya que su red es
dependiente de la de texas más de 4
millones de ciudadanos sufrieron los
estragos de la helada ya tenemos dos
días que no tenemos ni agua ni luz nada
de nada de agua ni ya no hallamos ni que
hacer ya nos acabamos la nieve que cayó
la tuvimos que cocinar para poder tener
agua para el baño y ahora ahí está en
cuestión de esto pues nos afecta a los
malos a todos los ciudadanos porque pues
la luz es indispensable es un bien
necesario que necesitamos para
sobrevivir ahora para calentarnos y para
cocinar y para todo esta ola de frío
intenso amenaza especialmente a la
población más vulnerable que no tiene
acceso a la calefacción